stacy abrams the pretend governor of
georgia stacey abrams ran for governor
of georgia she lost to brian kemp
and then
she just didn't concede she just
pretended she was governor of georgia
and even though she couldn't live in the
governor's mansion she would go around
and started non-profits to raise money
get her face out there
she goes on tv as though she's an
elected politician she's not she holds
no office
and if you were tuning into star trek
recently you would turn on and find out
that stacey abrams is not just a failed
gubernatorial candidate in georgia she's
actually president of the universe
stacy abrams
she lost the governorship of georgia she
gained
the presidency the chancellorship of the
entire universe according to an episode
of star trek
today
we greet the president of united earth
[Music]
madam president
president welcome i am so pleased that
you've come we are eager to begin
diplomatic discussions nothing to
discuss
united earth is ready right now to
rejoin the federation
and nothing could make me happier than
to say those words
thank you thank you all okay i've got to
fact check myself i don't watch star
trek and i certainly don't watch stacey
abrams so she's the president of earth
not not they they were they would never
be so ambitious as to say she's
president of the universe not yet she's
the president of earth and she's united
the whole earth and now they're going to
join i guess the galactic federation
with darth vader and i don't know i
don't watch any of these shows
the first thing i noticed about this
clip from stacey abrams if you're only
listening you wouldn't have noticed this
right now
they only ever have the camera on stacey
abrams for about two to three seconds at
a time
presumably this is because her
performance was terrible and so they had
to just construct her performance so
even as she's speaking it'll cut to a
clip of someone else it'll come to a
clip behind her because she's she's not
an actress she's a politician and a
failed politician at that but the libs
are so desperate to get her into office
that they are going to use everything at
their disposal not just the legacy media
the news media to lie about her and lie
about that election and give her the
biggest boost she can get in her
race to try to get the governorship
again but they're going to use hollywood
they're going to use everything
available to them to meme her into
office let me ask you something
why should stacey abrams be the governor
of georgia
even if you're i doubt there are very
many stacey abrams supporters listening
to this show maybe there are some though
we have liberal listeners we have
democrat listeners
what what is it about stacey abrams
that
makes her qualified to be the governor
of georgia
what has she done
what what does she do that means she
should be the governor of georgia
if stacy abrams's
supporters are being honest with
themselves
they will admit
nothing
nothing no accomplishment no particular
quality about her means she should be
governor other than her sex and her race
that is what that's why people like her
or that's why people pretend to like her
because she just plays identity politics
this is the only reason kamala harris is
the vice president
don't take my word for it that's what
joe biden said he said i'm only going to
pick a black woman
meaning i think it's electorally
beneficial to me to purely play identity
politics pick a black woman so i'm just
going to pick a black woman and he only
had three options available to him
really it was uh carol karen bass who's
that communist congresswoman like an
actual literal communist congresswoman
she wasn't going to work
kamala harris who was extremely
unlikable first out in the democrat
primary she didn't seem like she could
work or susan rice who was obama's fall
guy for benghazi
so of three bad options he picked kamala
harris she's the least popular vice
president in
recent history she's less popular than
dick cheney was after he shot a man in
the face after the iraq war after
everything that made him unpopular she's
very unpopular so why did he pick her he
said he only picked her because of the
color of her skin and her sex
why is katanji jackson the supreme court
nominee the only reason is because of
the color of her skin and her sex don't
take my word for it that's what joe
biden said
why is stacey abrams a thing only
because of the color of her skin and her
sex that's that's what the supporters
are talking about
now i'm not
downplaying her political skills she's
done a pretty good job of remaining in
the news even after she just keeps
losing even she should have gone away
after that election she's so she's she's
a clever and shrewd politician in that
way
but the only reason that people are
supporting her is because of these
superficial
virtual things oh she should be the
governor of georgia because she's the
president of the earth that's why
they're going to try to meme her
into office
and and this is a big problem
when you're living in a virtual world
then when real life problems come at you
you're not going to be prepared for them
when we're living in a world
of virtual problems
transgenderism
intersect white supremacy
systemic racism problems that are
completely fictional that only exist in
people's imaginations
then when vladimir putin rolls tanks
into ukraine people have no idea what
the hell to do
because that
that seems so old-timey well hold on
people still roll tanks into foreign
countries hold on there are still
invasions there's still war i thought we
were past all that i thought that our
biggest problem now was making sure that
hulking dudes can swim in the ivy league
women's swim championship wait you're
telling me we still have to deal with
real problems like territory and
geography and weapons and buffer states
and strategic interests and alliances
huh i don't know anything about that but
let me read you a poem by bono i'm
really good at that and that's all they
can do and that's why we seem impotent
and feckless on the world stage
[Music]